[Music]
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself
which houses frogs snakes crabs turtles
birds so many different life forms
human beings directly depend on
underground water source so a lake or a
pond is necessary to replenish these
groundwater resources
[Music]
you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
an achievable goal or just hot air we
examine boris johnson's pledge to turn
all uk electricity green by 2035.
stop breaking your promises nearly 2
million fair trade workers call on world
leaders to compensate low-income nations
affected by climate change
and show me the green way to go home as
google maps starts offering eco-friendly
routes we'll ask how much big tech can
help individuals do their bit
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions now it was a promise made
during the conservative party conference
but ultimately and perhaps unexpectedly
it didn't feature in boris johnson's
concluding keynote speech
this week the prime minister promised
that all uk electricity would come from
renewable and nuclear sources by 2035 a
date that's just 14 years away
anyone expecting more flesh on the bones
from mr johnson today might have been
disappointed but don't worry our science
editor tom clark has been looking at
just how attainable that pledge is
if the government is serious about its
net zero ambitions we're going to need
some detailed say analysts including
this former government advisor and given
the time scales we'll have to see them
soon
in order to to believe this is likely to
have a huge ramp up in uh renewables in
wind power offshore and onshore wind and
solar you're gonna have to have a huge
ramp up in nuclear this is a massive
challenge
innovators the kind we work with the the
catapult and industry are are up for it
um but they're gonna need clear
direction from government
his organization's latest report seen
exclusively by sky news finds under any
scenario the 10 gigawatts of offshore
wind power we currently have needs to
increase at least five times and
probably a lot more to meet net zero and
we'll probably need three times more
nuclear power than we have right now up
to 26 gigawatts but it also finds we'll
need huge amounts of zero carbon
hydrogen of which we currently have none
but it's closer than you might think in
this lab at itm power in sheffield water
and electricity is going into an
electrolyzer hydrogen and oxygen is
bubbling out
it's the r d behind the largest
electrolyzer factory in the world
its aim to make enough hydrogen to
replace increasingly pricey natural gas
everyone's committed to green energy i
think what we're really trying to
discuss is how we accelerate that
commitment and actually make it a closer
reality as opposed to it being further
afield and i think the commitment is
which green
energy supplies um electrons and
hydrogen not that it's not that it's one
or the other in terms of fossil fuels it
must be green renewable energy
to drive the point home just down the
road is a forecourt where wind energy is
converted to hydrogen on site used to
fill hydrogen-powered cars
in theory hydrogen is the perfect
complement to an electricity grid
dominated by lots of wind power because
on those really windy days when you've
got an excess of electricity you can
make lots of hydrogen which you can then
store to fuel cars power industry or
make more electricity on those calm days
when you haven't got any wind power
the challenge is turning that theory
into practice
a major commitment to renewables will
ensure a future for hydrogen but clear
policies need to be in place to deliver
a low carbon electricity grid and we
don't have them yet
tom clark sky news sheffield
so back to boris johnson's conference
speech now and it may have been short on
detail as far as climate plans are
concerned but there was a nod to the
difficult job ahead at cop 26 which is
now less than a month away
in just a few weeks this
country will host the summit of our
generation in glasgow when the resolve
of the world
is put to the test
can we keep alive the ambition of paris
to stop the planet heating by more than
one and a half degrees well government
can't do it alone and taxpayers
certainly can't do it alone
well our chief political correspondent
john craig is at westminster for us so
john was it a surprise that the prime
minister chose not to mention let alone
flesh out his brand new
green commitment in his keynote speech
well there wasn't much detail on any of
his policies he did refer to it i mean
in the run-up to that little passage we
heard about cop uh the prime minister
said we face a challenge uh even more
existential to our way of what life and
then he talked about cop now it was
monday when he went to visit a national
rail site that he made that pledge about
2035 and green electricity on that he
said today he talked about sorting out
our energy supply more wind more nuclear
becoming less dependent on hydrocarbons
from aboard which is the same message
just less detail there were quite a few
green references in the speech he talked
about 4 000 more clean green buses made
in this country uh some of them uh
running on hydrogen he talked about re
we're going to re-wild he said what
parts of the country consecrate a total
of 30 to nature planting millions of
trees and he did talk in quite poetic
language about those wind farms he talks
about going out into the murray firth to
see an aquatic forest of white turbines
towering over the water like the
redwoods of california and he spoke
about how important they were um doing
something to save the planet and get
britain to net zero by 2050. john thank
you
now nearly 2 million fair trade farmers
and producers have written an open
letter to world leaders due to attend
next month's cop 26 summit asking them
to keep their promises to low-income
countries disproportionately affected by
climate change well the letter outlines
four key demands and the first is for a
hundred billion dollars of climate
finance to be delivered now that's been
pledged by the richer nations to help
vulnerable countries mitigate and adapt
to the effects of climate change
next it asks world leaders to include
policies which will reduce emissions
from imported goods there's also a call
for low-carbon trade deals to help
farmers and businesses that invest in
sustainability
and finally it tells leaders to
strengthen business regulations so that
companies take ownership of the
environmental issues in the supply
chains well i spoke earlier to kate
mcarthur who's fair trade africa's
commercial director and began by asking
just why she felt the letter was
necessary the letter is so important
because it's just reminding the world
leaders of the promises they made in
terms of reducing emissions on climate
finance and ensuring that the business
climate is um governed by environmental
friendly
policies
so that those are just really reminding
them to deliver on their promise because
then the producers here in africa are
doing their best to mitigate and adopt
the climate changes
what fairtrade farmers are currently
doing they're planting trees in their
cocoa and coffee plantation to ensure
that the crops are shaded and that the
yields can somewhat um
remain as they were before and also
protecting the soils they've adapted to
using solar solutions for their lighting
for their cooking and also even uh
adaptive technology in terms of
fairly delivering standards and training
materials to them
well yes and we've heard in recent weeks
that president biden is pledging to
double the us's climate finance to 11.4
billion dollars does that give you
encouragement that world leaders are
stepping up
it's really a mixed feeling because the
previous promises only about less than
two percent actually got to the small
boulder producers so we can always
always have hope but we need to have a
great mechanism to ensure that that
the pledges are delivered and delivered
to the smallholder farmers so i'm glad
that the issue is coming up i'm glad
that they're promising more but they
actually need to act and ensure that
that money comes to the producer so that
they can um uh address the climate
changes after all most of the
smallholder producers are the least
emitters and there's too much burden on
them so it's good to get the the world
leaders to commit and deliver onto their
promise ultimately businesses are trying
to make profits aren't they and margins
can be pretty tight especially in this
country for example with energy prices
going up do consumers have to accept
they may have to pay higher prices for
climate aware products
currently we find some of our producers
some of our consumers sorry they're
already paying that price and that is
what is helping the fair uh
from farmers and smallholder workers
really thrive
but again what we are saying is it
doesn't have to be at an extreme premium
we're seeing as the
sustainable production sustainable
consumption um wave catches on there
could be additional costs that everyone
within the supply chain will cover but
the more we do it from the consumers
from the business partners from the
governments then over time with
economies of scale then you find that
the the premium doesn't have to be that
high for the consumers to pay and what
we are noticing now is that consumers
who are who are buying sustainably
produced products could be fairtrade it
could be any other it going a long way
in ensuring that the farmers are getting
a fair wage that goes to
meet their basic needs like food
education uh really basic needs that um
any any consumer any producer needs to
be met
in today's other climate news now a
climate protester interrupted a catwalk
at louis vuitton's paris fashion week
with a banner condemning the effects of
fashion on the environment the woman
representing friends of the earth in
france extinction rebellion and youth
for climate was then wrestled to the
ground and hustled away by security
guards
workers on the greek island of evia are
building wooden flood barriers to
protect coastal villages there that's
because devastating wildfires destroyed
the plants and trees which would
normally absorb rainfall around 300 000
acres of forest and bushland were burnt
across greece this summer amid the
country's worst heat wave in 30 years
and google has revealed that it'll be
launching new sustainability features
the search engine will allow users to
view emissions estimates when searching
for hotels or flights and google maps
will start including greener routes
investors will also be able to receive
portfolio scores on google finance in
order to calculate how eco-friendly
their investments are
well do stay with us coming up after the
break i'll be joined by podcast host
marion pascha and climate advisor to the
white house jerome foster and we're
going to be discussing what climate
leadership should look like and in the
light of that google development where
the big high tech can help us go green
thank you
[Music]
the best innovation comes when there is
a need and a problem to solve
rarely have we faced a more testing time
join us live from yorkshire for the
first in a series of sky news in
pertinent events where we will explore
how to fire up uk business watch
thought-provoking discussions with sky
news experts on building a stronger and
greener economy
think big with us big ideas live on sky
news
i witnessed how the catalan fight for
independence split families it was from
this chamber that carlos putimon
declared independence in october
i come here because i want to show other
people what happened
i'm michelle clifford and i'm skye's
europe correspondent
it's not the aim of the smugglers to
actually get people to uk shores but
simply into british waters
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are real concerns here now about
whether the health system will be able
to cope
president macron has spoken in defense
of freedom of expression saying france
won't give up its caricatures and
drawings
made by people who dare to challenge
afternoon mr barnier how are you
i have no time for any politics
[Music]
anger about wider social and economic
problems in this nation
we are on the verge of fascism and we
have a country
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
did you know if we tried to use less
energy we could help reduce air
pollution
what like turning off the lights and
stuff yeah
northern and western parts will be
largely overcast with outbreaks of rain
in the northwest and patchy drizzle and
hill fog elsewhere eastern britain
meanwhile will be mostly dry with sunny
spells it's going to be warmer than it
has been recently but it will be windy
for many the afternoon will bring little
change with northern and western parts
staying dull and damp into the evening
the southwesterly wind will bring clean
air from the atlantic so the air
pollution index where one means low
pollution and 10 means very high will be
low
everywhere the air quality report
sponsored by philips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with host
of the climate curious podcast mariam
pasha and white house climate advisor
jerome foster say good evening to both
of you good to see you both
so first of all boris johnson's speech
today was i think it's fair to say light
on policy detail it was also pretty
light on references to climate change
now compare that to a speech to the un
general assembly a couple of weeks ago
which he dedicated entirely to the need
for action on climate change and as the
host of the huge cop 26 climate summit
in glasgow coming up in only a few weeks
what does this say about his leadership
and how should leaders approach climate
action
so mariam to you first of all so there
was little reference to it in his
conference speech but we did hear from
the prime ministers this week making a
new pledge to turn the power grid green
by 2035
the latest some would say in a line of
quite ambitious climate targets so is
that what good climate leadership looks
like
i do think that the time for pledges and
commitments is kind of coming to an end
i think people will need action i think
we need to know how we're going to get
there and how what it's going to mean
for every single person that lives in
this country and i think
pledges are a great place to start but
it seems that if we end there we're
never going to be able to take the steps
we need to take
to
address this climate crisis
would you agree with that jerome that um
targets are all very well but you have
to spell out to the public to businesses
perhaps the fellow politicians that you
need to get on side as well
what it means to reach those targets and
do you think that
jo as an adviser to joe biden do you
think he's doing any better on that
front
absolutely i think that when we talk
about the differences between the uk and
the us right now the u.s has a whole a
government approach and we talk about it
from an electric vehicle standpoint from
a job standpoint and from an overall
solution standpoint and we have the
details and i think that's what is was
really encouraging about the us is that
we are working towards that and we are
seeing tangible results but but but joe
biden has a fight on his hand to
convince everybody in government hasn't
he to to come on side with some of the
plans it's not all straightforward there
yeah absolutely right now we're seeing a
3.5 trillion dollar infrastructure bill
which if passed would accomplish many of
this administration's goals and that's
really a challenge right now over the
next um week or so we're working to
convince other elected officials that
this is an urgent priority and has to be
tackled um with the details at the
forefront well yes and finance is really
important isn't it mary i'm not just in
convincing fellow politicians there are
different departments within government
that are all vying for money in a
post-covered era but also you've got to
convince the public as well who might
worry that it's going to cost them more
these plans to go green it that's that
takes leadership doesn't it
absolutely and it's also about really
showing
all of us here in in in the uk that
actually by
reaching our agreeing to targets by
making
those this you know those pledges and
and actually attaining them that we're
actually going to be able to live up to
some of the
um
targets that people want in their own
lives when it comes to jobs and health
like the the environmental targets we
set also let us achieve other things
that people do already care about so
it's not just about diverting everything
to the environment but looking at how
all these things intersect well yeah
it's really interesting you mentioned
jobs actually because jeremy i'm just
going to point out what joe biden has
said about jobs and the green economy he
said it's going to create millions of
jobs i think it's a gigantic opportunity
to create really good jobs and clearly
joe biden's strategy is trying to frame
this as a kind of positive economic
step but is that cutting through people
are worried there aren't they about jobs
in fossil fuel industries going and and
the country's really quite divided on
the climate question isn't it
i think that it actually is very
straightforward when we talk about jobs
it's when we talk about workforce
development we transition people who are
working in fossil fuels to now install
solar panels and wind turbines it's a
jobs perspective at the very forefront
every solution will create millions of
good-paying jobs and the biggest thing
that we're working on right now is
called the civilian climate court which
would mobilize millions of young
americans to be able to work directly in
the the solutions that will save us when
we talk about the cost of solutions we
have to talk about also the cost of not
implementing them the cost of natural
disaster devastating communities is far
higher than the solutions that are
needed that also will have a positive
job impact as well
okay and interesting to see if that does
bring people on side let's move on to
our second uh subject now though shall
we and google announced today various
strategies to help consumers act in a
more sustainable and eco-friendly way
now this is all quite light touch stuff
but considering how big a role these
companies play in our daily lives what
are their responsibilities and can big
tech help us go green
so mariam just to illustrate some of
what they're doing google have said that
they're giving a a green badge to lower
emission flights and eco-friendly hotels
they've also got features like maps
defaulting to eco-friendly roofs is this
a good idea is it going to help us
be nudged towards making more
sustainable choices in our lives
giving people more information and more
data is always going to make it easier
for them to make informed choices i
think that transparency is absolutely
great and i think that people will be
able to make those choices in an
informed way now but whether that
putting this responsibility on the
individual entirely is a good idea i
think quite it's it's not i think we
need to also understand that this is a
whole society that needs to act together
so if this helps people do their part
that's great but we can't stop here
because so how much further should we go
do you think then i mean you you think
the business tech company should do more
well i think the big tech companies do
have one really big responsibility which
is about addressing misinformation about
climate change that is something that
they have in their control and has a
massive um impact on the way that
individuals
understand the climate crisis and that's
we've seen the influence these companies
have had in things from elections to
vaccines and so they need to take that
responsibility when it comes to
information on climate change as well
well it's interesting actually i think
because
google did say today that in a bid to
combat misinformation uh users who head
to google search with questions about
climate change they'll be shown data
from sources like the united nations as
well as trusted news sources on that
that issue that's what they've said
jerome what's your take on this what
role
can these big companies play in helping
us change our behavior
this is a very encouraging step to see
from google and
tech companies in general but i think
that also we have to ensure that we
aren't placing the blame just like
miriam said everyday people did not
cause the climate crisis it was the
companies in socioeconomic systems that
created the climate crisis in the first
place so they must be the first and
foremost to to basically break the
solutions and that looks like them
changing their logistics in the supply
chain not telling everyday people that
they should make small incremental
choices it's in both and i think that's
that's really good because also i think
google has made some steps but we need
to see much more when it comes to the
next decade of mobilizing on a massive
steel to avert the worst
impacts
so very briefly you think they do have a
responsibility they're not just
companies who are free to do what they
like
oh they have an absolute responsibility
to protect people because they create
services that pollute the environment so
if they're continuing to do that they
have to say we're going to switch to
make sure we aren't continuing to harm
people and communities it's 100 on them
to change and it's a small
impact people have sorry to cut you off
your own but we are out of time jerome
foster marion pascha really good sibo
thanks very much indeed
so we're out of time but do stay tuned
with us here on sky news for sky news
tonight described as a gift to the world
especially africa the latest on the
first malaria vaccine
[Music]